and ladies and gentlemen I tried to
bring you the best I try to bring you
the best and then dr. Joel wallets work
has resulted in the publication of more
than 70 peer review and and and referred
journal articles in the fields of
nutrition and pharmaceutical research he
promotes worldwide health beauty and
youthful energy and for more than 40
years it has been dr. Wallach smishing
to bring accurate and timely health
information to the world ladies and
gentlemen I want you to stand to your
feet and welcome our speaker for the
next couple of nights as he takes us on
a journey to achieve in the health that
we want please welcome dr. Joel Wallach
as he comes at this time this program is
meant to present nutritional information
only and is in no way meant to replace
the advice of your medical doctor and
now the superstar of alternative health
and purveyor of medical truth dr. Joel
Wallach thank you pastor dollar and
pastor Taffy and his whole crew they've
been so wonderful really appreciate the
help that everybody's given and I have
to thank the greatest physician of all
right who has always been who is and who
will ever be the greatest physician our
Lord Jesus and we love him forever and I
know he loves us forever cancer big
thing big thing cancer right that's
pretty scary but you can prevent cancer
100% by again avoiding the bad things
prevention is always easier it's kind of
like putting oil in your car before the
engine burns up you put it on your car
before the engine burns up you don't
wait until the engine burns up to see
well let's put a little oil in there
don't get all crazy about trying to get
healed when you can prevent it it's real
simple okay much cheaper much less
painful and you'll add 25 healthier
years your life okay next cat-scans
which doctors will tell you harmless
actually have 400% more radiation than
they used to think you had twenty-nine
thousand new cancer patients every
which half 14,500 died after just one
cat scan you know you can get an
ultrasound a high-definition ultrasound
for 50 bucks tell you the same
information they can see the valves in
the pea-sized heart of a little embryo
human embryo it's just a month old
that high-definition ultrasound there's
no radiation to it no risk cost fifty
bucks that can't scan cost 4,000 next
high fiber diets do not cut colon cancer
risk as another old myth high fiber
diets do not cook cut colon cancer risk
this is a study on on 90,000 nurses and
50,000 male doctors over a 20-year
period the Harvard Nurses Health Study
there is no problem I mean just high
fiber guys didn't help got the same rate
of cancer from high fiber ties to low
fiber diets but when you ate a high
fiber diet because of the risk of celiac
disease because fiber is usually wheat
gluten or oat bran or something like
that increases your risk of diabetes and
heart disease and stroke and other stuff
don't eat high fiber diets
there is no benefit in fact there's
unintended consequences that are not
nice okay next look at that fat doesn't
increase your risk of breast cancer you
can actually eat 90 percent of your
calories from fat as long as you don't
fry it next this was a another study
only 15 years of
I think it said 15 years Harvard Nurses
Health Study 90,000 nurses you take a
high-end multivitamin like our mighty 90
not a one-a-day centrum or something
like that it won't work because only has
like 32 is the mighty 32 instead of the
mighty 90 you take the mighty 90 this
reduces your risk of colon cancer by 75%
are there any drugs that will do that no
next
let's see here
study finds very well-done meat linked
to breast cancer you can reduce your
risk of breast cancer ladies by 462
percent by eating your meat cooked
medium or medium rare
if you cook your meat very well-done
where it's burnt where the fat is burnt
tastes good but the killer the devil
comes in many guises including burnt fat
I mean think about it you know Hellfire
and burnt I mean that's the devil sense
of humor there okay next we've known
about selenium being able to prevent and
cure certain types of cancer since 1912
since 1912 we've known this and I had to
sue the FDA I sued the FDA and won in
federal court they appealed and I beat
him in the appellate court and then they
appealed and they signed off on the
steps of the US Supreme Court for me be
able to say that the tracer no selenium
can prevent certain types of cancer the
trace from selenium can help your body
make certain anti-cancer substances just
to say those simple things I had to sue
him three times in federal courts but
the truth want out there in that case
we're able to beat the FDA to death on
that one thank you okay next this is
just another thing on selenium is a big
study out of the University of Arizona
just taking 200 micrograms of sley and
1/5 of a milligram of selenium it'll
reduce your risk of prostate cancer men
by 69% colorectal cancer both genders by
64% lung cancer with you smoked or not
by 39% anybody who smokes and doesn't
take the mighty 90 with a little extra
selenium is foolish aren't they now I
can guarantee you ladies if you take the
mighty 90 you will never get prostate
cancer I can guarantee you that
next next oh I love this one
arsenic can prevent and cure certain
types of leukemia arsenic we've known
it's essential nutrient necessary to
prevent certain types of cancer certain
types of leukemia since 1947 and that
funny
okay next okay preventing cancer is very
easy once you get it it's a full-time
job to treat it as a chronic disease you
can add five or ten or fifteen or twenty
or thirty years to your life when you
have cancer but you're gonna be working
24/7 for the rest of your life it's much
better to prevent it that way you have a
life right it's much better but we can
work with you if you do have it you're
salvageable through God's grace this
program is meant to present nutritional
information only and is in no way meant
to replace the advice of your medical
doctor
you